[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday march 17th i'm
cindy you the spectators broadcast
editor and your host this week
on the show
boris johnson is in the gulf trying to
persuade saudi arabia and the united
arab emirates to release more oil
supplies and ease the global energy
crisis will they i'll speak to james
forsyth and katy balls and the former
american diplomat david rundell
delegations from russia and ukraine are
meeting again to try and negotiate a
peace deal what more should the west be
doing to support president zielenski the
historian timothy garton ash will be on
the show
katan jews also writes in this week's
issue fact-checking western politicians
claims that our cost of living crisis is
down to the russian invasion
kate will be on to argue why the war
shouldn't be a cop-out for governments
and finally what links our royal family
to the romanovs the family that ruled
russia for over three centuries the
royal biographer robert hardman joins
the show
before we get going a very special thank
you to canaccord genuity wealth
management who are sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes canaccord are experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who go above and beyond to offer you
support and guidance just visit can do
wealth dot com to find out more
and remember to subscribe to our youtube
channel too click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
boris johnson is this week meeting with
the rulers of saudi arabia and the uae
asking them to pump more oil to ease the
west's energy crisis but has he already
failed i'm joined now by james forsyth
the spectator's political editor and
katie balls our deputy political editor
also joining the show is david rondell
former american diplomat and author of
vision all mirage saudi arabia at the
crossroads
now katie despite much controversy
surrounding this visit that boris
johnson has made to the gulf states it
doesn't seem to have yielded much
results so do you think the visit has
been a flop this week
i mean i think it depends what we judge
on was there an announcement immediately
saying yes the saudis are pumping more
oil and it's going to help in the uk in
terms of cost of living no and instead
we got a statement after it was you know
saying they agreed to keep working on
strategies to work together on energy
and so it doesn't feel as though there's
a quick win here
but we're also not hearing that the trip
uh was it you know disaster so i think
that if you're looking at i suppose
building up that relationship so you can
get to the point where you get to the
end goal you know
in a few months time perhaps there is
some progress there um but in terms of
something boris johnson can come back
and shout about not so much
and david the british pm said that it
was within saudi arabia's interest to
help the west but it doesn't seem like
mohammed bin salman necessarily agrees
with that why is saudi arabia reluctant
on this front
well
saudi arabia is reluctant at the moment
to break the agreement that opec
plus has
laboriously created
uh this was not a small achievement
getting opec
members to agree
and more importantly getting russia to
join in with this agreement was a major
achievement for the saudis and for
mohammed bin salman himself
and
they're not
likely to throw that
out the window
uh
quickly or easily because it would be
particularly difficult to resurrect in
light of what's going on with russia now
that if they are seen to be unreliable
uh partners in opec
i think the russians would be very
reluctant to join with them in the
future
can you talk a little bit more about
this deal for
viewers who don't know about it what
does it say what does it do why are the
russians involved
okay
i think to back up just a moment and
explained that saudi arabia is the only
country in the world that maintains a
large buffer stock
or excess capacity of
oil production
most days the saudis have about 2
million barrels of spare production that
they can turn on and turn off
this is a political decision not a
commercial decision
bp or exxon would never
drill wells that cost literally billions
of dollars
and then just shut them down and hope
that they might need them on a rainy day
the saudis do that and when there is a
hurricane in the gulf of mexico that
shuts down production or there is an
invasion of kuwait that shuts down
production or there's a
strike amongst the oil workers in
nigeria or venezuela or quite frankly
when the united states
and its allies decide that we're going
to put sanctions on
iran and stop them from exporting oil
who steps in to fill the gap so that
there's not a big spike in the price
this is the saudis
second thing to know is why do they do
this
and the answer is because they have a
great deal of oil they want oil to
remain part of the global energy mix for
a long time
and they realize that if
a
the price of oil gets too high people
will find alternatives or put the third
set of insulation in their house or
something that to reduce demand that or
they'll start drilling in some very
expensive place like the north sea or
alaska so they don't want the price to
get too high and they don't want and the
third second thing it could do is it if
it gets too high it drives the global
economy into a recession
and then that also destroys demand and
finally they don't want the price to be
too volatile
because if the price is
wildly unpredictable people will have to
again find an alternative so for all
those reasons they try to keep the price
at a
an affordable and reasonably stable
uh
price
uh they can't control the market but
they can influence it and they do that
by on a monthly basis adjusting how much
they
pump
so that's the background the agreement
that they negotiated with the russians
was um basically for the last couple of
years they have brought
russia into a
an informal actually it's becoming more
formal uh agreement
that um
while they're not officially a member of
opec they go along with the opec
quotas
and
the agreement they have had now for over
a year is that they're going to increase
production
first of all you have to remember that
they were asked by president trump um
when the oil price was crashing
to actually reduce
uh their production to keep the price up
so you know everyone goes to the saudis
some days they want them to increase
some days they want them to decreases
but in any event when the price
collapsed during cobit
production went down
now it's going back up as people recover
from covid and it's the agreement was
that it would go up by 400 000 barrels
every month
and they have been sticking to that
agreement and i think that they will
continue to stick to that agreement so
they are not going to they are actually
increasing the uh
the amount that they produce uh at a set
amount every month as they believe we're
recovering from cove what they were
unwilling to do was to
break their agreement and
re-uh pump more more quickly so that i
hope that answered your question it does
thank you david and james from the
british perspective then how important
is securing the support of
the gulf states like saudi arabia in
tackling the western uh cost of living
crisis that's coming down the line
so it is clearly important in terms of
the resilience of the western coalition
uh against russia
on ukraine and maintaining uh public
support for sanctions now
i think there has been a u.s strategic
miscalculation here which is i mean as
the u.s became uh more and more energy
independent the u.s wanted to get away
from all the difficulties of uh and the
moral complexities of a relationship
with the house of saud the biden
administration
called saudi arabia pariah during the
campaign
after he was elected um joe biden
released the us intelligence assessment
blaming mohammed bin salman for
the murder of jamal khashoggi a
washington post uh columnist
and i mean the us thought that they they
didn't need this relationship with saudi
arabia now because uh because shale uh
was making the u.s so much more energy
independent what i think the u.s failed
to realize is that because it sits at
the apex of two alliance structures in
europe and asia
you know what matters is how energy
independent
the rest of the alliance is and it's
turned out that the rest of the alliance
is nowhere near as energy dependent as
the u.s is so saudi arabia is still very
important
i think mohammed bin salman now might be
in danger of making a strategic
miscalculation himself
which is uh i think he is clearly uh
enjoying the fact that the saudi the
blind administration which has refused
to deal with him so far is now going to
have to deal with him uh boris johnson
you know having canceled two previous
trips to saudi arabia has you know flown
thrown out to see him this week but i
think the danger is if it looks like
saudi arabia is not going to help by
pumping morale saudi arabia will lose
its place as the west's indispensable
interior on the oil market
and what you will see
is the west saying right let's come to a
quick deal with iran and the nuclear
negotiations in vienna so we can get rid
of sanctions on iranian law and get that
back into the world market which will
deal with uh reduce the leverage that
vladimir putin has now i mean the irony
here is that one of the reasons one the
saudis are for understandable reasons
very unhappy about the fact that they
feel that too many concessions are being
made to tehran in these negotiations
already but if saudi arabia does not
indicate that it is prepared to help i
think the west will be more inclined to
cut a quick deal with iran
rather than
go through kind of five visits to saudi
arabia to try and persuade them to help
i mean mohamed bin salman has an
opportunity here and he is in danger of
missing it well david what do you make
of that because at the moment the
juncture that we're at at the moment it
does seem like countries that are
non-aligned like china india saudi
arabia and are having a lot of pressure
put on them to be more leaning towards
the west so it's an incredibly sensitive
moment isn't it
well i think that the comment was
completely correct that uh the idea that
the americans were
energy independent
uh
was nonsense
because
clearly
oil is traded on a global market
and the price is set globally and our
allies and trading partners are heavily
dependent on imported oil even if we're
not uh we have to buy at a global price
and we have to hope that we want our
allies to prosper
so that was the idea that we didn't need
saudi arabia was a foolish idea uh
to begin with
and i think again that it's also true
that if i so i re in the end i would
agree with that i'm not sure that the
saudis see it that way i don't think
they're going to break their agreement
with opec i think they see that as a
long-term uh commitment that would be
very difficult to resurrect if they
break it now so i don't think they're
going to break it i could be wrong
and i think they do run a risk then of
uh bringing iran back into the market
the question is how quickly iran can
come back into the market and how much
it can really add that it's not already
selling under the table so to speak to
some people like
china for example so i don't i don't
know how much that's going to really
solve things but i do think that speaker
is correct that there is a danger that
the fight the other i would also i would
add to that though that um that the
biden administration
um wants to do a deal and will is is
almost desperate to get that deal and
would have been desperate to get that
deal
regardless of the price of oil
and katie just going back to the british
side of things kierstama i alluded to
earlier has been criticizing the
government for making the trip like this
but does labor have an alternative for
solving this kind of problem
yeah i think it's an interesting one
because you have a situation where kids
dama has been very supportive of the
government's response in terms of
russia's decision to launch a full-scale
invasion of ukraine and has actually
said you know we're holding off on
calling for the prime minister to go now
now is not the time and generally is
pretty aligned when it comes to comments
on nato um when it comes to you know
just uh sending defensive weaponry or
all those things and on sanctions yet
um we start to see the rub this week you
all said angela rainer the deputy leader
um
questioning really why you would get
into conversations with saudi arabia as
evident labour when you try and press
down on their exact position which is
would you not have a relationship would
you refuse to you know use oil from
saudi
it becomes less clear i think there's a
little bit of a gray area but ultimately
we're heading to a big cost of living
crisis and one of those supposed
advantages being the opposition you
don't have to have solutions people will
ask you for them but you're in a
position where you can point at problems
but i do think that without a new supply
of oil more oil and entering the market
for the uk it's really hard to see how
you're going to get around what's going
to be a very painful cost of living
crisis even with this the expectation
the treasury is that uh the cost of
living will still be bad it's just a
case of you know damage limitation in
terms of how bad so
i think that
labour's position
something you would expect will please
the membership but it's actually a bit
tricky when it comes to how they would
really cope with this because ultimately
being in government means particularly
on oil talking about iran i mean iran
doesn't have a great human rights record
um it means dealing with lots of
countries which aren't the people
perhaps you would choose to make your
number one ally in other circumstances i
was just going to comment you know
quickly
that i it would be a mistake to assume
that all of these priced increases are a
result of
what's going on in the ukraine
there has been a war on hydrocarbons
brought forth by environmental activists
and this is part of the price of that
okay this price increases in oil was
going on long before the invasion of
ukraine and president biden made a
specific uh plan
to basically end he wants to end the
hydrocarbon industry he wants he shut
down the keystone pipeline he canceled
leases he increased regulations he did
everything that the so-called greens
wanted and the result is less oil being
produced
and oil is it's a market and there's
supply and demand but i would argue that
even more importantly than his um
shutting down keystone pipeline or other
pipelines
is the
emphasis that all of this is having on
banks and on oil companies as bp and
shell decide they're not going to be oil
companies anymore because the
environmental activists are incl are
pressuring their board
so if you're not going to drill for oil
uh and you don't have a realistic
alternative
uh
which you don't at the moment you're
going to see energy prices go up and you
know i think all the people who were
listening to little greta um didn't
really think about what it was going to
cost them to clap
so they're paying now and they're going
to keep paying until they figure out
that right now you don't you need oil
and whether you whether you like it or
not uh so i think that you know to blame
this all on putin and ukraine is a
mistake we've brought a lot of this to
ourselves
yeah very interesting and james finally
you mentioned iran earlier obviously the
other big news this week is the return
of the british iranian aid worker
nazanin zagari ratcliffe how does all of
that play um in in the in the greater
context is boris johnson actually doing
better on the foreign policy side he's
having a few wins at the moment
well i i mean the the the the brutal
truth
is that the uk paid this debt that it
owes iran and that is why she has been
released i think it also
is a sign of uh improving relations
between iran and the uh and the west
that because the talks in vienna are
perceived to be making progress you know
it it is easier for the uk to to kind of
find workarounds to the sanctions to
release this money and say it's only
going to be used for humanitarian
purposes but i think it does reflect uh
a slight warming in relations between
western capitals and tehran
i think on the oil price i mean there's
a it's important to note that the price
is down about 40 dollars from its recent
peak and and that is because you know
china is the world's largest importer of
crude oil and you know there is a
growing expectation in the market that
the fact that china is dealing with its
worst covered outbreak since wuhan in
2020 means that um the chinese economy
is going to be interrupted chinese
demand for oil is going to fall and so
and so the global price will go down so
i i think there is a kind of i think
that i think the in terms of the oil
price the situation looks
uh
less uh i think i mean we are probably
moving into an era where oil prices are
gonna not gonna quite reach the levels
that some people thought they were gonna
reach just a few weeks ago uh but i
think there is a but i think one of the
other aspects of this crisis is it is
going to revive the debate in the in the
west about energy independence i think
it is going to lead to more nuclear
power more renewables because you know i
think that th this this oil diplomacy is
uh making g7 states again reflect on
whether whether this dependence is
sensible or not
and you write about that china situation
its implications your political column
for the spectator this week so viewers
can read that as well david rondell
james forsyth and katie balls thank you
for joining spectator tv
positive noises are coming out of the
negotiations between ukraine and russia
with even an advisor to president
zielinski of ukraine are showing some
optimism what could that endpoint look
like and what more can the west do to
strengthen ukraine in the meantime
in this week's magazine the historian
timothy garton ash makes three
suggestions he joins the show now
so timothy thank you so much for joining
spectator tv in the magazine this week
you write about uh what the west can do
to help ukraine you outline these three
options can you give us a brief overview
of them
absolutely i'm in the question of
questions we've seen this heroic
extraordinary
ukrainian resistance how can we help
them
three big things all of which come from
president zielinski in his tweets
number one more weapons
particularly air defense weapons and
supplies to help them resist a siege
because that's what's now happening in
almost
medieval siege of ukrainian cities
secondly more sanctions and
the big one here is oil and gas
at the moment germans and italians and
others in the eu are still paying
billions of euros effectively
into putin's war chest to pay their
heating bills
and that would be a really major move
which would cost countries like germany
very dear economically
but as i argue there's a moral cost to
not doing it right and then the third
big one which zelensky asks for is
accept ukraine as a candidate for eu
membership and there i argue that the
eu's not going to do that anytime soon
but there are lots of big things we
including britain can do
to have a big reconstruction plan
and to bring ukraine gradually closer to
a european future
can i pick you up on sanctions first of
all which is that um you say that is
going to be expensive for the germans i
think yeah it definitely will be um do
you think they're not going far enough
now then because they have already said
that they have already sanctioned some
of these russian companies not to the
extent that they're not importing uh the
resources but also that they've said
that they'll reduce russian gas by
two-thirds by the end of the year is
that not enough
how many ukrainians would have died by
the end of the year i think that's the
answer to the question listen because of
the big mistakes we all made in not
reducing energy dependence after the
caesar crimea in 2014 they're in a bind
make no mistake
30 percent of
germany's total primary energy supply
comes from russian oil
gas and coal it's enormous if they make
the stop
the estimated hit is between
one and three percent of gdp or one
thousand euros ahead so it's a big
economic cost
but as i say
are you really going to go on paying
putin with every heating bill when
ukrainians are being massacred in the
way they are but what is the realistic
middle point because you can't just wean
off overnight so
is it realistic for germans or any
europeans to do that
so interestingly the big profit maker
for russia is oil
so one way to do this
i is actually to start by stopping oil
imports and take a bit more time over
gas
the good news is we're coming into the
summer you don't need so much energy in
the summer but you know what the popular
outrage in germany is so immense as it
is in britain that i think this may yet
happen
and timothy on the military front uh
nato has ruled out this no-fly zone as
zlensky is asking for uh citing concerns
that putin would use as justification to
attack nato but somehow people have
argued that putin clearly needs no
justification for aggression so it
doesn't really matter almost and if
zalensky's asking for it maybe we should
have that what do you make of that
argument
well
what i say is nato is not going to do it
that's what's clear and i mean they've
been already joe biden has been
absolutely clear about it jens
stoltenberg has been absolutely clear
about it
so we could have a hypothetical
discussion about what would happen if
and the answer is
you know putin is capable of anything
but realistically it's not going to
happen and so we have to do everything
short of that mark and actually what i
gather from the experts is that if we
can get in
sophisticated uh
anti-aircraft air defense missiles
that's in a way as important as um
getting in those you know polish mig
planes or
a no-fly zone which would be a no-fly
zone only against the russians
and i want to talk to you about this
zielinski plan you're you're writing
about tell us about that
yeah um well i'm fed up with people
keeping saying you know we have a new
marshall plan because you know they've
been about i i can personally remember
about seven proposed martial plans that
never happened for former yugoslavia you
name it for east central europe uh so i
call it the zelinski plan but
listen the the the war damage is already
estimated at well over 100 billion
dollars that's clearly an underestimated
the russians are still pounding away so
it's hundreds of billions and the least
we in the west can do
is to have a big reconstruction plan
and my argument is by the way that's
also rebuilding the homes to which the
millions of refugees in the rest of
europe will go home so that's important
for us too
but my argument is to connect it to some
intermediate steps of connecting ukraine
more closely to europe
well it's a fascinating idea and there's
the sweetener i guess to those
concessions that you allude to can we
talk about how this will end because it
does seem like zelensky may have to make
some of these painful concessions
so
as i say in the piece i pray daily for a
miracle on that nipper
like the miracle on the vestila in
1920 when the poles defeated the
advancing red army and and the red army
simply retreated
but that would be a miracle
and barring miracles neither side can
win and therefore they're going to have
to fight their way
i'm afraid through rivers of blood sweat
and tears
to a point where there's what um
lawrence friedman the strategic thinker
calls a hurting stalemate when both
sides are hurting so much that they have
to make a deal
and
only the ukrainians have the right to
say what that deal is
you know can be
but we can at least start thinking about
it now zielinski
yesterday
tuesday um we're speaking on wednesday
said
i don't think we're going to become a
member of nato so he's already in effect
saying okay we can go to neutrality
what's really painful is going to be the
territorial concessions crimea and
donetsk and luhans the provinces in the
in the far east of the country
and that that that's really tough to
take
would i mean let alone zelinski do you
think the ukrainian government the
ukrainian people would accept something
like that
so i talk regularly to people connected
with the ukrainian government at the
moment the public position is no
but and of course
we should in no way shape or form be
kind of forcing this on them that we
have absolutely no right to do that
but privately they will acknowledge
you know these are facts on the ground
the comparison i draw with the so-called
winter war between finland and the
soviet union in 1939 to 1940.
um
stalin thought he'd roll over finland as
putin thought he'd roll over ukraine in
fact the poo the finns put up the most
magnificent amazing military resistance
gave stalin the bloody nose
and basically six months later they
signed a piece
they had to give up about one-tenth of
finnish territory brutal concession
but finland remained a free
sovereign independent democratic country
and i think every finn
you speak to would say that was a price
worth paying
and finally timothy i just want to end
on this note that you make about
zelensky
obviously his performance i think
throughout all of this i think many
people can agree has been exceeded
expectations of an actor comedian um you
also mentioned his trita feed as a
master class in 21st century war
leadership tell us about that
so i
every viewer should
should follow him on twitter it's
absolutely amazing by the way when i
started he was just over 2 million
followers now he's well over 5 million
in the middle of this war in risk of his
life after every conversation with a
western leader biden or schultz or
macron boris johnson or whoever it is he
just has a tweet
saying what they talked about and doing
his main points then he does these video
clips
around besieged kiev
his messages to the ukrainian people and
the russian people it is an absolute
master class in political communication
and the effect is you know
the ukrainians have already won the
information war
the russians are still fighting the
military war but the information war
they've just won
hands down so it's like you know imagine
winston churchill with a twitter account
that's a great note to end on timothy
gardenash thank you very much for
joining spectator tv
now the war in ukraine is obviously an
incredibly significant development with
deep domestic repercussions around
western countries but k andrews has
noticed that this has provided
politicians with something of a cop-out
as they try to blame some of their
outcomes of their own policies on russia
instead here's joe biden from last week
talking about record high inflation in
america
make no mistake inflation is largely the
fault of putin i love you know the
republicans biden's gas pipeline
so i'm sick of this stuff
we have to talk about it because the
american people think the reason for
inflation is government spending more
money
simply not true
kate join spectator tv now
kate we're hearing a lot about how the
russian invasion means that we're going
to be facing a higher cost of living but
you write in this week's magazine that
actually that's not to blame for all of
the rises in the course of living and we
shouldn't let the government off the
hook there tell us about it
yeah so boris johnson this week penned
an article for the telegraph where he
talked about how weaning
europe off of russia's gas and energy
was going to be a painful transition but
one that we needed to take and on many
accounts that's completely true
especially if you're looking at
countries like germany where in december
2021 it was estimated that 32 of their
gas imports were from russia alone
that's going to be a very painful
process here in the uk it's roughly
three percent far less painful to wean
ourselves off but of course as there's
more competition for energy from other
countries that aren't buying from russia
that means our prices go up too so these
are all very legitimate points but it
also means that the prime minister has
decided to start talking about the cost
of living crisis and preparing the
public for the cost of living crisis all
within the context of what's happening
in ukraine and no doubt it's going to be
connected no doubt it's going to make
the situation worse but if we look at
things like energy inflation and
certainly tax hikes the trajectory of
all of them was going up and up and up
long before we brought in economic
sanctions and certainly long before
putin put his army's boots across the
border in ukraine so it is a bit
disingenuous let's say to suggest that
this is all about ukraine but i think
there's increasing indication that
that's how the government is going to
try to frame it
and it's not just the british government
because you point out that biden is
doing a very similar act right now
yes so joe biden's actually been leading
the way on this and americans aren't
buying it
he talks a lot about putin's price hike
that's the phrase he uses just recently
he said to house democrats that the
inflation that america has been
experiencing was putin's inflation now
look america's inflation headline rate
hit a 40-year high it's well over seven
percent now
months before we get to russian's
illegal invasion into ukraine um so
again it's not to say that that's not
going to have an impact it's certainly
going to make things worse and if we
look at say the price of a barrel of oil
i think you can much more directly
connect that to what russia has done to
ukraine and the economic sanctions that
we've taken against them uh the us and
the uk is following in banning russian
oil completely uh and the import of it
so you know that's a good example where
you can draw that direct comparison but
for biden to suggest that putin is
directly responsible for essentially all
american inflation when he has been
printing borrowing and spending
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars more over the course of the
pandemic
uh it doesn't quite fly i mean people
understand that the monetary decision
making around coven 19
and and the implication of that has been
hugely inflationary to the point where
the march 2021 budget that rishi sunak
was putting together here in the uk
was designed to try to make the uk as
biden proof as possible against uh the
possible uh the possibility of rising
inflation because of all the borrowing
and spending that he was doing so you
know inflation has been on the cards for
a really really long time um and
the the another point to make here is
you know it's always been really
difficult to
disentangle the impact of say brexit and
covet on things like the labor market
it is also going to be hard to
disentangle the impact of this war that
russia has uh launched against ukraine
and the impact of two years of crazy
economic policy
of governments shutting down their
economies and kickstarting them again
it's going to be hard to completely
separate that but it is simply not the
case to say we are only dealing with
these price hikes now because we've
decided to take action against russia we
were going to be dealing with a cost of
living crisis if none of this had ever
happened
yeah and i remember kate that you know
this time last year and even earlier you
were writing about the inflation that's
going to come after covert is done and
we are seeing exactly that now um so
it's not just risky scenic but uh not
just like up to you too much but you've
been writing about it yourself for
months
well there was indication
around this time last year when we were
leading up to that march budget and it
wasn't just coming from inside whitehall
it was also coming from economists like
larry summers over in the states who is
not traditionally hawkish when it comes
to inflation who was saying look this is
unprecedented what you're doing shutting
down economies pumping this much new
money into the real economy actually
putting it in people's pockets
deflationary pressures of the past china
coming online the influx of labor that's
been cut off in many ways by brexit
these things are not going to keep
inflation down and we should be
preparing for higher inflation um and
nobody was taking these minority voices
very seriously so i was just simply
writing about them i found it
interesting and you also had at the time
that now the former chief economist of
the bank of england andy haldayan saying
look no one knows what's going to happen
but the risk is to the upside and and
those minority voices completely turned
out to be right as it turned out the you
know the economic roles that we've
always known that we thought perhaps
were coming to an end this idea that
inflation and interest rates would just
stay at rock bottom no matter what we
did
when it comes to monetary policy turned
out not to be true the the old rules um
reared their ugly head so to speak and
we're dealing with the impact now um
another good example of this is energy
prices here in the uk rishi sunak was
putting together in early february this
year again before russia invades before
sanctions a 9 billion pound package to
help people with their energy bills this
year because offgem has lifted the
energy price cap by 54
because energy is becoming so much more
costly um you know there's just example
after example of how the cost of living
was going up before russia's war um i
really don't want to say that you know
russia has is having zero impact here
obviously now energy bills are going to
go up even higher and that will be
directly linked to what we've had to do
uh to to stand in solidarity with
ukraine and what we've rightly done uh
to try to put pressure on russia to back
down
but a lot of western politicians joe
biden i think increasingly you see boris
johnson here
hinting at the idea that you know what
we're about to experience this pain this
economic pain that we're going to
experience here in the west is because
of putin
partially but it's also because of a lot
of decision making from these
governments here right here at home
over the past two years
right because it's not just energy
prices which arguably the governments on
either side can't really control if it's
a global phenomenon but things like the
national insurance rise which you write
about which is absolutely a government
decision cindy you're completely right
that governments cannot dictate the
market price of energy nor should they
really try to do that but of course
there are government policies that can
make the situation better or worse and
the energy price cap here in the uk has
put dozens of energy companies out of
business so you know we have seen where
perhaps the government could have done
better on energy policy and has failed
to do so taxes are a really good point
though i mean this is wholly in the
government's control
and we have that national insurance
height coming in next month 2.5
percentage point increase split between
employers and employees
and this was sold on the idea that it's
going to help with nhs wait lists and
wait times post pandemic it looks like
we're not going to get great results for
that money but the real aim of that
money is is not pandemic related at all
it's to pay for boris johnson's social
care plans which aren't really plans
it's it's going to subsidize the wealthy
it's going to protect their assets so
they don't have to pay for their care if
they were to
fall ill in old age
no guarantee it's even going to add a
single bed
to the care home crisis but the key here
is that that was also ushered in with
the idea of an emergency the tories
breaking that tax manifesto pledge not
to raise national insurance was broken
because there was a crisis
and they ushered in this other kind of
policy and you can you can see something
a little bit similar with a narrative
happening now boris johnson saying look
this next phase of economic pain is
going to be because of what's happening
in ukraine well yes partially but also
because of other decision-making
including that tax hike
in the piece i had a tory mpc to me and
i'm sort of paraphrasing this now
that the narrative has fundamentally
shifted
not only is partygate out of the news
because of the war but also there is
this new thing to pin everything on any
kind of pain that we experience we can
now pin to russia's actions even if that
isn't the full answer
yeah that's definitely an effective
narrative do you think people either in
the uk or the us are buying it in the uk
i think less so but they're also ahead
in that headline inflation rate i mean
they're experiencing these price hikes
more acutely the uk isn't all that far
behind
so i think that you know that will get
more judgmental here that will get worse
here
but in america the right had already
taken to calling it biden's inflation
and i think that is part of the reason
that president
biden is now trying to frame it as
putin's inflation um so you have already
a a narrative debacle going on there
about pointing fingers who's responsible
for what
look anybody paying their bills this
winter anybody who's you know even been
buying basic goods knows that prices are
going up uh they've already been feeling
that that cost of living squeeze before
this war broke out so i think that you
know generally speaking in their gut the
public will know that this is a
combination
of of crises of things that have gone
badly wrong um and you know you can
argue that as you were saying cindy
about energy prices that's not in the
government's control many will argue
that you know lockdowns certainly at a
certain point start the crisis were
necessary there was always going to be
economic pain that came out of this
i guess the real question is
did the government honestly prepare the
public that the decisions that we made
in lockdown to pay people salaries to
pay people to stay in hibernation to
keep us locked down for as long as they
did months on end sometimes that that
was going to have real consequences for
years down the line and are they being
transparent now you know the rishi sunax
mini budget his spring statement is next
week and it will be interesting to see
how all of this is framed he was one of
the few voices
last year he was warning about
inflation you know he knows he knows
full well the the risks that were
associated with all of this long before
uh putin launched his war so how will he
be framing this what will that
conversation be like with the public
because we can only pray that things
come to a halt and putin turns his
armies back asap
but let's say hypothetically speaking
that happens that even some sanctions
are dropped the public needs to be aware
that that cost of living crisis doesn't
completely go away with some kind of
victory in ukraine yeah yeah that's very
true and speaking of that spring
statement then kate what can we expect
from rishi sunak
i would be surprised if you didn't see a
nod to the cost of living crisis um
you know if he didn't address that in
some way perhaps with some small
giveaway or some small tax break um but
i wouldn't expect to see a major
response to the possibility of energy
price hikes in the autumn because the
next time that the energy price cap is
set and raised will be around october
and at the moment the estimates range it
could be 500 pounds it goes up by it
could be 2 000 pounds it goes up by for
understandable reasons the treasury is
not going to want to commit to a subsidy
policy or a handout without actually
knowing what those figures are so i
would i would expect that to be shelved
for a little while
and i would expect to see something
relatively conservative because that
fiscal headroom that sunac has been
building in that we know he's desperate
to use for tax cuts
is being eaten away by inflation
servicing the debt those payments are
going up by billions and billions of
pounds a month on month as inflation
rises um as as he was warning could
happen
um and he knows that he's going to have
to prepare probably to help people with
their energy bills a bit more later in
the year
so you might get something in reference
to the cost of living crisis but it is a
mini budget and i expect to see
a relatively conservative chancellor
taking conservative action
and i guess now is a great opportunity
to plug our live coffeehouse shots event
next wednesday in the emmanuel center at
westminster so a real physical event
where you'll be able to see kate uh
chatting with frozen nelson katie balls
and james forsyth to give you their
reaction to that mini budget so that you
can get tickets uh on the link on the
screen right now kate thank you so much
for joining spectator tv
and finally the royal biographer robert
hardman joins the shame in this week's
issue he writes about the blood ties
between the romanovs russia's last royal
family and the british monarchy
so robert hardman welcome to spectator
tv first can you start by telling us
about this complicated family tree
between the british royal family and the
romanovs
well uh
queen victoria was always described as
the the grandmother or indeed the great
grandmother of europe because everyone
pretty much is sort of interrelated via
her
um and down through her uh
came uh
prince philip's great aunt
um who married the last tsar of russia
um down through her mad kane obviously
queen elizabeth ii but also came prince
philip prince philip and the queen both
great great grandchildren of queen
victoria um but also off one side of the
family tree is uh is
is prince philip's grandmother and her
sister um married uh nicholas ii um and
so he was really quite closely connected
i mean so closely as i've said in the
article that he was asked to
if he wouldn't mind providing a dna
sample
um back in the early 90s for many years
people have been looking for the bones
of the romanovs
and there was an academic who was pretty
sure he knew where they were but he
deliberately left them
untouched until communism fell he was he
didn't he
distrusted the regime he didn't think
they would be safe in communist hands
but once
russia opened up these bones appeared
and they needed to be authenticated and
prince phillip um
did that
that's amazing and and also after the
bosch revolution uh prince philip seems
to have grown up around people who used
to be you know the top ruling class in
in russia well exactly i mean you know
the russian revolution um he was born in
1921 so i mean this was sort of live
stuff um and the family uh while he was
a baby had to get out of greece uh very
quickly his father um was charged with
um trumped up charges by a military
court and it was really thanks to the
intervention of
king george v
um and british
diplomats in athens they got the family
out his father was the the younger son
of the king
but he was in the army he was blamed for
this catastrophic defeat against the
turks
and they needed a scapegoat it was going
to be him however
a british destroyer turned up in athens
managed to get the family out just in
time prince said it was a baby and
famously was carried aboard this british
warship in an orange box um and they
went into exile they went into exile in
paris
and at the time you had all these
uh remnants of sort of russian nobility
russian royalty uh slowly um escaping um
the clutches of the bolsheviks uh and a
lot of them ended up in paris and a lot
of them would sort of meet up and and
and see a lot of each other because they
didn't have much else to talk about the
good old days yeah exactly talk about
yeah
certainly uh you know the sort of uh and
back in the days of the tsar and uh and
one of these characters grand duke
dimitri who was a distant cousin of
prince phillips it was obviously a real
character um he used to come around to
their house quite a bit to sort of tea
and tell his stories and and i mean he
really one of his stories is quite
extraordinary he was one of the men who
helped to murder rasputin rasputin was
the uh the the the the sort of this this
bogus shaman figure this sort of monk
like um uh
alleged genius who um had a sort of hold
over the tsarina um and a lot of people
had caught thought he was a roman and
decided he had to go and uh he he
famously it
didn't go easily but um eventually they
um they they famously killed him and
pushed him under the ice and all the
rest of it uh and and one of those
involved one of the plotters one of the
murderers was was cousin dimitri um but
uh who who prince philip adored um yeah
well he he says that he remembers him
fondly yes i mean he was he'd have been
a sort of you know schoolboy he was a
primary school at the time he went his
first school was in paris uh but this
larger-than-life character turns up with
all these tales of old russia um and he
was absolutely spellbound i don't
probably i didn't i didn't talk to him
about uh the other side of grand dimitri
a bit of a playboy who ended up as a
lover of uh coco chanel i'm not sure
that that was discussed over the tea
cups in the suburb of saint cloud uh but
you know these sort of characters loomed
large i mean it is often said that you
know prince philip was more more royal
than the royals um because he was
really was connected uh via this sort of
extraordinary um dynastic diaspora
and so uh
you know fast forward to
the end of communism and he was
absolutely fascinated i mean he had been
back because he among his many hats he
wore he was
president of the international
equestrian federation for many years
very very influential president i mean
he changed a lot of things he
rewrote the rule books and a lot of
sport
but he happened to be
president at the time of the moscow
olympics so that that took him over to
russia not as a royal but as a as a sort
of senior sporting administrator and so
on those trips he would um he would come
into contact with the sort of soviet
high command
um and
of course the moscow olympics became
very controversial because in a sort of
foretaste of what we're going through
today
uh russia had just invaded afghanistan
uh and a lot of people were boycotting
those games um and a lot of people
weren't uh and he decided just to step
back his his particular sport um decided
to leave it to individuals to decide but
he himself
um refused to go to to the moscow
olympics um he just thought it would
just be too controversial but so he he'd
had some experience of soviet russia uh
and also
on those sort of periodic moments when
uh britain would be trying to sort of um
seek a bit of a thaw in the sort of cold
war before dear uh
russian leaders would occasionally come
to britain um and
in in the mid 50s he and the queen uh
entertained uh bulgarnin and khrushchev
who uh of course the the
were the two two top men in in the
kremlin at the time uh and they came for
they came for drinks at uh windsor
castle um i did certainly get a sort of
state visit but it was sort of cordial
welcome
and as i say in my piece um prince
philip told me that uh he he took them
into the queen decided to greet them in
the waterloo chamber and in there
there's this enormous portrait of
of czar alexander the first
uh and
and so they showed there these these two
communists you know here is uh this is
the only russian we've got on the walls
there he is sort of thing uh to which
they went oh yes he was he was a great
patriot oh yes though he was a great man
in our history uh which they thought was
a bit you know that's interesting
because you're
you're you're hardcore bolsheviks and
you murdered a lot of them uh but i
think it just showed that um rather as
we see with with putin now actually that
sort of in a russian patriotism sort of
trumps class warfare um at that end of
the the kremlin
um and he as prince philip said they
said they had this sort of chat and he
said and then we took them through to
the red drawing room which seemed rather
appropriate um but so you know all
through the cold war and
he he took this great interest
not just in it for sort of dynastic
family reasons but because you know he's
a he was a very distinguished uh
member of the armed forces until he had
to step down and he always all through
his life
um was fascinated by uh all all the
forces and and at that time the the
number one threat to those forces was
was russia so uh he he was very well
informed on all aspects of of the cold
war
yeah and just talking about the end of
the cold war then how excited was he um
how did he feel when the ussr fell
because you spoke to him on the eve of
this 1994 state visit by the queen and
prince philip to russia what was he like
oh he was he really was very excited um
i mean he he he and the queen had sort
of played a a part in
in
making that state visit come about some
years before um because uh when mikhail
gorbachev was was as it were
bringing down the or opening up the
gates however you want to put it but at
that period of of what we call uh
perestroika and glasnost um
they came
gorbachev and his wife came to britain
in 1989. and margaret thatcher's
government
were very keen to sort of lay out the
red carpet
and that included a trip to windsor to
see the queen and they had this
lunch at windsor and after lunch the
queen sort of laid on a special
exhibition of all various various bits
of sort of russian memorabilia um to
just to sort of you know make him feel
at home things i think i think a faberge
egg was was uh retrieved from the royal
collection uh that sort of thing uh and
uh and and and they they they kind of
hit it off i mean you know gorbachev was
genuinely touched to be given this sort
of royal treatment and at the end of
that lunch i'm sure it had been
pre-prepared by the diplomats but at the
end of that lunch he formally issued an
invitation to
uh to the queen to come on the state
visit um in the meantime by the time the
state visit happened he'd actually been
kicked out and boris yeltsin was in
charge um
but but yes the dude was was absolutely
thrilled to be going on this trip well
and robert finally just part of that
trip was organized by a deputy mayor
called vladimir putin yes yeah uh hit
the the the person who'd organized the
petersburg end of things uh there was
the mayor of the city but the person who
did all the all the the sort of the the
groundwork was the deputy mayor whose
name was vladimir putin um and uh i did
ask the sir robert you know i said what
do you remember putin he said he didn't
say very much
uh you know classic kind of xkgb colonel
um you know ostensibly organizing a
royal visit but probably working out
where to plant the bugs
um
but it it has to be said i mean in an
act it was a very
it was a remarkable soft power actually
that the the key side where britannia
was birthed um which is where the um the
original russian warship the the aurora
fired the first shots of the revolution
always used to be known as the english
embankment
and uh in honour of the queen and
britannia they put the name back to it
it had a soviet name in the meantime
they they renamed it the english
embankment whether they're still going
to call it that now i've no idea it
would be called the putin embankment by
now but uh
it was it was
looking back on it it was an
extraordinary few years there was a real
sense that you know this dark period was
over and here was this great optimism
yeah that this part of the world was
going to come around to um
to a western way of thinking i mean i
don't think anyone expected them to be
sort of rushing to join the eu or you
know suddenly uh adopt um uh
european ways instantly but
there was clearly a sense that
uh that
uh now is the time to to reach out and
it was a very it was an interesting
visit because
um i spoke to the uh
british ambassador
sir brian fall very distinguished um
british diplomat um who
uh he was obviously very keen for this
visit to happen but there were a lot of
cautious voices in the foreign office
saying oh it's a bit soon ooh not sure
don't think we wonder oh let's wait
uh classic sort of whitehall um
dithering um and uh it was you know so
brian was saying no no come on we got to
go now because
this is the moment you know that the
whole place is is in chaos um and
yeltsin needs he needs the sort of uh
imprimatur if you like of a visit from
somebody like the queen there aren't
many people who can really you know stop
the traffic um and she's one um and she
was very keen to go she'd always wanted
to go and she had this invitation from
gorbachev and uh
and they off she went and it was
uh it was just one of those visits that
you you look back on and think well that
was that was extraordinary and it was
the first and sadly the first and only
um state visit um putin came on a return
visit um some years later nine years
later
he was welcomed to london and given the
full treatment taken up the mall in the
carriage procession and given the state
banquet didn't really look as though
he's enjoying it terribly much just sort
of going through the motions
and then very soon afterwards um russia
started to sort of retreat into itself
um but for that sort of 10 15 year
period um
you know there was there was a sense
that um that the entire world order was
changing and there in the vanguard of
that sort of transformation was the
queen and prince phillip
a different time robert hardman thank
you so much for joining spectator tv
thank you
that's it for this week
once again we're delighted that
canaccord genuity wealth management is
sponsoring the week in 60 minutes
canaccord will provide the expertise you
need to build your wealth with
confidence you can visit
candoowealth.com to find out more
and if you enjoyed this episode don't
forget to subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon so you never miss an
episode thanks for watching and do join
us again next week
[Music]
you